after bad things happen compassionate
people people with a even somewhat clear
understanding of reality will say oh I'm
praying for you I'm thinking of you and
I'm praying for you and then Libs will
scream and yell at them for it or make
fun of them for it so yes thoughts and
prayers that's all yes do you keep your
thoughts in prayers and shove it what
are you offering you're just offering
invective and bile and you're mocking
little kids for being Christians and
being murdered what are you offering
we're offering gun control laws the gun
none of the gun control laws have ever
worked you've passed plenty of gun
control laws they haven't done anything
well we're offering anger oh thanks oh
thank you that's that's what we have a
shortage of is anger oh your anger is so
comforting what are you offering well
we're offering uh cruel jokes about
murdered children and Christians oh cool
thanks I think I'll stick with thoughts
and prayers if you are against thoughts
and prayers after a tragedy that's a
pretty good sign you're on the wrong
side